[Music]
I'm the one
for for many reasons a lot of people
want to talk to our guests today okay
Tom your your thing keeps hitting the
table I don't know what you got your
cufflinks or whatever that is yeah so
Tom's been in trouble all morning today
folks I don't know why Tom's just doing
a lot of stuff today but today's guest
Dr Peter Navarro if you don't know who
he is you probably haven't turned on the
television you don't follow politics
because if you do turn it on you're
gonna see him some people love him some
are indifferent some don't like him but
his background is absolutely insane with
his expertise and a few topics that we
definitely want to get into and we've
been following up for a minute to get
him here finally our uh buddy here Malik
AKA Rob was able to make this work let
me let me properly introduce with the
background
um he served in the Trump Administration
as assistant to president director of
trade and Manufacturing policy and the
National Defense production act policy
coordinator he was previously Deputy
assistant to the president and director
of The White House National trade
Council uh wrote a book uh he's written
a few books one of the books was death
by China which we'll cover there's
another one that just came out a few
months ago we'll talk about that as well
he's a strong advocate for reducing U.S
trade deficit and has been critical of
Germany and China accusing both nations
of currency manipulation he supports
increasing the size of the American
manufacturing sector setting High
tariffs
which is something that uh you kind of
got to bully some of these guys and
that's one of the ways of doing it he
went to tuft University on academic
scholarship by the way just so you know
the alumni of that school is a pretty
heavy duty one Tufts
Tufts yeah
did he really my best friend yeah Jamie
Diamond went there you got Peter
Gallagher you got Meredith I think
Meredith yeah she yeah she went there as
well right Meredith Vieira when there's
it's a very uh well-known School served
in a U.S Peace Corps in Thailand for
three years earned a masters of public
administration from Harvard University
John F Kennedy School of government in
1979 and a PhD
in economics from Harvard under the
supervision of Richard E caves in 86. a
few things has run for office multiple
times lived in San Diego you were a
Democrat while going to Harvard then you
became a registered Republican in 1989
then you went registered as an
independent in 1991 when you ran for
mayor of San Diego as an independent
then you rejoined the Democratic party
in 1994 remained a Democrat during his
subsequent political campaigns he was
endorsed by then
first lady Hillary Clinton holy moly
during his 1996 campaign for Congress
and positioned himself as a progressive
on social issues such as Choice gay
rights and religious freedom then
Navarro supported Hillary Clinton's 2008
campaign and then Barack Obama's
environmental policies and entering the
2016 presidential campaign Navarro
identified as a Reagan Democrat and a
trump Democrat abandoned by my party uh
and obviously supporter of President
Trump what a wild background you have
thank you so much for being a guest on
the podcast it's it's great to be here
uh the one thing you left out of my
video was actually grew up
um
in this area my father was a
professional musician
and he played he had his own band and he
played uh like the fountain blue and
Eden Rock oh nice and then the good days
yeah yeah when they were just brand new
right and uh and then we'd go up the
pike to Palm Beach and play play the
Palm Beach Towers there
and um I spent the better part of my
childhood riding my bike past uh what
was in the post estate now do you know
what the post estate is now is that the
Mar-A-Lago Mar-A-Lago yeah yeah so I bet
Patrick it's great to have me back here
I think you know the the political
discussion that you said about my party
um switching and all of that I think it
it it's a good place to just put down a
marker here
on what Maga is what the make America
great movement is and the other part of
my veto I think that's interesting is
that I was one of only three
senior White House officials who served
with President Trump from the campaign
in 2016 all the way to the end only one
of three think about that you're going
in the the you know the the odds uh uh
me
lasting the whole time given all the
politics that was in there but Mago to
me and this is why I'm I'm a trump
Republican a Reagan Democrat Trump
Republican it's it's it's it's it's got
such a bad rap Lately from the the
progressive wing of the Democrats but
but while Maga is make America great
again
um is three things it's a triangle they
call it the Iron Triangle of populism
it's it's at the top of the the pyramid
there it's a strong American
manufacturing base and resilient Supply
chains which gives us the employment
opportunities the rising wages and by
the way the National Security we need
when we have pandemics or Wars and you
get that through things like you
mentioned tariffs but also buy American
hire American which I was the the point
guy in the White House on the second leg
of the triangle is the secure borders
issue
um where as we speak we are having the
the biggest Invasion
um of illegal aliens across our Southern
border which brings a whole host of
issues I'm all for immigration but but
we have to have a way to ensure that
that's going to benefit the people in
this country and right now that's not
the case and then the Third part of that
triangle is an end to the endless Wars
the the afghanistans and the iraqs that
you know being in the Senate people to
the Hindu Kush to get blown up by IEDs I
got a lot of questions but that's Mega
anyway that's good for you to share that
I want to start that but we we want to
talk about uh China with you yeah you
know on how to manage that my concern is
also what did we learn from China on the
way Nixon and Kissinger set it up for us
to make sure you know with India India
just passing up China they have the
youngest population comparing the two
you know they're gonna slowly but surely
become a Powerhouse and how do you
manage that relationship long time and
how different is the India relationship
versus the China relationship we'll get
into that as well some things came out
with a recording with you and uh the
lady that is also trying to thank you
yep we'll we'll talk about that I want
to get your thoughts on that uh
obviously I'll get your thoughts on
Tucker we'll get your thoughts on
Dominion with the 787 million dollars
with Fox what is happening there and a
few other things but I think probably
the most important question to ask you
before we get into it are you more of a
Bud Light guy or a Coors Light guy I
think that's about that's the number one
question I think that's what everybody
wants to know everyone listening right
now it's a tough answer
at my age okay I'm the boringest guy in
the world because I cook everything I
eat
and uh I don't imbibe anything I got a
problem you know this is like when I get
sick there's nothing I can give up to
make me better so
um I'm more of a water guy I respect you
the question
it's just never worked for me if you're
the one cooking yeah your wife's not
cooking you are are you only cooking and
you're buying and eating American food
oh no that's interesting I can't think
of a single thing
uh that's imported in in what what I
have yes it's it's uh Adam's right now
at a phase of his life that he's he's
trying to figure out
he's trying to find his Eve and can she
cook American food so he's mentally and
emotionally struggling right now
so although you know you guys I don't
see any coffee here so that's cool not
allowed not allowed yeah so so coffee
and onions my coffee is uh dark dark
dark dark chocolate which invariably has
to come
from abroad
there you go Panamanian extra dark hey
you know like that I need you to stick
to that iron triangle and make sure it's
made in America by America okay thank
you for policing me so so let's talk
about a few different things you you've
been criticizing China for a long time
and you know whether it's the books
you've written about them whether it's
the tariffs whether the criticism you
got if we do punish them they're not
going to come back they're not going to
do anything to us we've all seen and
read the same stories and watched the
exchanges that you've had what's what's
your biggest concern with China uh on
where they were before where they are
now are they becoming more powerful are
they getting weaker because there's a
community of people that are saying
behind closed doors China's not doing as
good as people think this whole concept
of the one child family that they did
they backfired on them because they're
getting older people are leaving they're
not even sticking around anymore
billionaires are leaving job creators
are leaving that thing's about to
collapse is it a real threat as it was
before are they getting weak or what are
your thoughts on China it's the greatest
existential threat
um this country in the world faces that
that that that is clear let me let me
let me let your folks know it's like
I started writing about this back in
2006 I wrote a Trilogy of books that
come in China Wars
um in 06 death by China which was both a
book and a film in 2011 and just before
I went into Trump Administration
Crouching Tiger the first two books were
about the economic threat the last book
was about the military threat now the
punch line here is that as bad as I said
it was in those three books as much crap
I took from the Legacy Media and all uh
kind of like oh no no
um
I'm the guy who had a top level on like
Hunter Biden uh I got a top level
security clearance I get to see the
highest level stuff without giving any
secrets away I can tell you that
whatever I said about China
in my books is far worse
far worse and if you just here's the
thing it's like
I was with President Trump by his side
when he went face to face with the
dictator Xi Jinping right and one of the
one of the advantages they have is that
that that that they don't have elections
right so their their team right their
team is the same team when we faced him
as it was with Biden right I sat face to
face with these guys and what what Trump
tried to do and I think it was uh was
was a uh the right thing to do given the
political climate at the time I wanted
to come in hard it's like you know these
people you can't trust them just put the
tariffs on them and make them stop doing
what I called the seven deadly sins all
the crap they do to steal our jobs in
factories and then he said no no no
we're gonna we're gonna Stanley put on
some tariffs but we're gonna try to cut
a deal with them and you know in Buenos
Aires we sat face to face you know Osaka
Japan we sat face to face with the G20
and all we learned my friend is all we
learned is that they're just stringing
us along that uh whenever you sit to
negotiate with them they'll agree pretty
much to anything and then at the end of
the day they just wait you out and they
break every agreement you set so you
can't so the policy needs to be and I
think president Trump was clearly going
to adopt this as soon as that second
term began is what we call decoupling
decoupling the U.S economy I don't know
if you know this but the trade deficit
we have with communist China never call
it China it's communist China let's be
clear about what it is
is about roughly equal to their defense
budget so in effect every time we go
into Walmart
Target and buy that crap
which usually is stolen designs from
American
designers
we're funding what is an incredible
Arsenal pointed at our Navy in
particular in the South and East China
Sea
and they look the threats are many and
very but you just start with asymmetric
Warfare what is that that's being able
to sink a five billion dollar aircraft
carrier with a one million dollar
missile okay they've got there's a
chapter in my my uh Crouching Tiger book
you know missiles are us I mean they got
more missiles than any country in the
world you know they're they're they're
just they it's like as Stalin said
quantity has a quality of its own they
can hit the palace in Taiwan in seven
minutes from the mainland and you know
what they you know what they call
aircraft carriers
American aircraft carriers in China
communist China targets right it's just
it's like a stupid wave it's a stupid
way to conduct Warfare with communist
China you you don't put big aircraft
carriers in this Taiwan Straits and not
expect those things not to get shot down
I mean we should be putting all our
money into uh sea mines ringed around
Taiwan if we if we want to take that
democracy seriously and and and
submarines
just quiet submarines so let me ask you
so you you said a lot of different
things you said it's a lot worse than
you think it is when we want to
negotiate it with them I was in those
rooms and we're sitting with these guys
and we're talking to them they would
make all the promises they would come
back they would literally break every
single one of the promises and the
negotiation outside of that they got
more missiles than anybody else they can
sink a five billion with a one million
dollar missile and they can within seven
minutes attack the Taiwan you know
Palace all of that stuff is public stuff
that we know okay what I want to know is
if you're saying if you're saying it's
worse than what you know right yeah what
do we not know that is worse than what
we know well the the broad Strokes have
to do with
um the elements of for example China
2025 which
um the made in China 2025 yes and and
the idea was that strategically they
want to
take over uh the key strategic
Tech sectors that are going to determine
the future so AI is certainly one of
them blockchain let's talk about
blockchain technology okay
um what what we need to know okay and I
I there's certain things that can and
cannot say but but the question is
blockchain technology is the technology
which you is used to encrypt things like
Bitcoin and and all our banking system
and if you
um have the key to unlock
that
blockchain technology
as a weapon of Warfare when the time
comes you can bring down the entire
Financial system
of the United States in in nanosec when
the time comes when the time comes and
when would that time come for example
Xi Jinping okay you mentioned okay some
people are saying China's not that that
that doing that great and they got
trouble and this that and the other
thing well that's that's dangerous
because
if Xi Jinping gets into domestic trouble
the first thing he's going to do is what
you know the expression
Wag the Dog Wag the Dog is going to mean
a run on Taiwan we're gonna have to have
some kind of reaction and you know what
do you do do you send carriers into the
South China Sea as soon as one of those
sinks gets game on or do you blockade
um the the the routes that China or that
oil comes from the Persian Gulf to China
I mean they they're 70 of their oil
comes from the person I mean as soon as
that kind of stuff happens
than the asymmetric
Warfare what they call the unrestricted
Warfare kicks in that's like knocking I
mean they have the capability right now
they can knock our satellites out of the
sky they can use
viruses
probably to take out our electric power
grid
and all these balloons that you've seen
floating over the United States that's
part of their information gathering
process to execute their unrestricted
Warfare techniques when the I mean it's
just it's just the only thing holding
them back is the fact that that we're
their Cash Cow we're the tit they suck
on right we're we're it we're Uncle
sucker and and the way they lifted 250
million peasants at least up into
statuses sweatshops was by running big
trade surpluses with the United States
so this I mean this is like it goes on
and on and on I just I wrote this in
2006 it reads like a pentagon report
today and we all we get is all we get is
rhetoric and so BS from the corporate
media and the Congress so let's so let's
stay on that so these these Double D's
that China keeps sucking our nipples off
of right yeah they're very they've been
doing it for a while and they're
flattened a little bit okay the last
couple years so you know because now uh
or especially when Trump was there and
you were there and you tariff after
tariff after tariff after tariff hey
Huawei CFO was in Canada doing a deal
with Iran and we found out guess what
why you're out boom Huawei loses a third
of their valuation a that person's doing
what they're doing boom I was in Monaco
and I'm sitting there talking to a
pretty connected guy in politics from
Lebanon who was doing a lot of the
things for the uh countries there and he
says you don't even understand the
tariffs Trump put in Iran how much he's
hurting Iran's economy right now how
much they're being affected I'm in this
on a daily basis I'm having these types
of conversations you see what's going on
so
let's look at both sides so the only
reason why they haven't yet they can
they can they can they can attack Taiwan
they can do this to the you know
Financial system they can do a Cyber
attack they can do all these different
sorts of things right and hey the fact
that they are going through the bad
thing we got to be careful because all
Wag the dark concept you know what's
going to happen next okay cool so why
don't they well because they're sucking
on our nipples so if we do put the
tariffs
and we keep it there
and we make them drown
to the point of catastrophe happening
there then it's definite that they're
gonna do something no yeah and that's
not look that's not that's not the goal
the goal
the gold is a strong America and the way
you get to that is simply wean yourself
from
the factory floor of communist China and
their supply chains we if we've learned
anything from the pandemic we will be a
stronger more resilient country if we
have our manufacturing base and our
supply chains here or at least much
closer
to here and China look if we totally
decoupled from communist China they'd
still grow I mean that that Genie's out
of the bottle they they're in Africa
they're in all South America uh the
Europeans welcome them with open arms
but this is not about that this is about
defending ourselves peace through
strength and his peace through economic
strength it's peace through National
Security and this whole thing look
these folks you talk to oh well they're
hurting Iran this that and the other
thing the problem is since we've gone at
it with half measures it's actually
strengthening communist China's hand in
places like Iran why because they are
using this American sanctions right what
are Financial sanctions sanctions are
like you can't trade in U.S dollars if
you do X right right so if if if Iran
gives weapons or whatever to the
Russians in the Ukraine is sanctions
whatever
but the problem is that if you are able
to create a Yuan Ruble based currency
system
then you don't have to worry about
sanctions and so every time we've
imposed sanctions in a half measured way
it's given Russia
Iran and communist China the incentive
to create this alternative currency
world and right now they're going hard
at it I mean Brazil and Lula yes that's
like Brazil under Lula is like a colony
of the Communist Chinese Peru is it very
much at risk as well and the reason is
what they call the debt trap diplomacy
that's where China will come in and
they'll they'll just shower these these
countries with money in order to get
infrastructure in there and and there's
there's so much grift associated with it
that the leaders will skim off the top
and put their Swiss bags guys in you
turn around and next thing you know
China
forecloses on the port in Sri Lanka and
now they own it and that's like a
strategic Naval Hub so I mean this is a
big three-dimensional chess game and
we're playing checkers I want to ask you
one one more question and then Tom I
want you if you and I think you got some
thoughts you want to share so here's a
question on this so
um
in in a competitive environment which we
are right now it's a competitive climate
that we have but it's from ideology
competitive environments different than
capitalism capitalism you're trying to
get a market share here a market share
their region you know all this other
stuff politics is the way you think and
as well as some resources right and
they're doing a very good job with
getting the right resources you know
Iran Africa they're doing the right
things from the competitive standpoint
but
if
if we go back and look at the case study
of tariffs because I am for tariffs in
many cases the part that was for me uh a
bit strange is China not letting any of
our media companies being in China
Facebook YouTube all this stuff but we
have to use your stuff here
that to me is is is a dumb negotiation
tactics I'll lift the tariffs if you
allow all our social media companies in
your country because we got to know what
you got going on and I'm not lifting
these tariffs until you do that because
my concern is we need to know what the
hell your people are happy about not
happy about you can find out about our
people you can go on Facebook and see
all these videos with George Floyd the
you know the video it's oh my god look
what's going on in the U.S hey look
what's going on in the streets look
what's going on with antifa that's
what's going on great you have you have
that access to all that data we don't
have access to all that data so I do
think
we have to use tariffs in a way for us
to get more citizen journalism in China
for us to say that's how you treat
people we're not for that's how you do
this we're not for it and then we can
get more common sense freedom of speech
freedom of assembly freedom of idea
freedom of all this stuff being injected
in China and then the Chinese people are
going to say look we don't like the way
you're doing this we got to kind of
change so I think the social media
pushing and our media being in China
will be my number one thing that's me
then the other part is we're giving you
all this money we're not getting it in
return you're winning from us now you
got 80 percent of chips all our ACS are
pretty much being made in your country
when covet happened you shut down your
manufacturing we couldn't do anything
with cars car prices went up 45 60 you
know the average car payment today in
U.S went from four years ago being 550
to 917 a month when the income hasn't
really increased dramatically that's a
massive increase on what's going on so
Americans are now feeling it but that's
the question
um how does one based on the years that
you were with President Trump
what did you learn for the next people
that are going to come in and maybe if
Trump goes in or maybe you know another
person is in the white house and it's
not Biden's Camp because you say you
have security clearance Hunter Brighton
has the kind of clearance you don't even
have uh and it's a different kind of
clearance it's called a data clearance
and and you don't have that kind of code
no I know I know you're very excited
about your career but his clearance is
more effective than yours because he's
able to make off money off that
clearance and you cannot although you
look nice I'd buy a painting from you
that's yeah you look like an artist
that's a good point but but going back
to it so imagine I paint left-handed by
the way just to exercise the other part
of my brain power yeah so much the
better so whoever the next
Administration is going to be yeah so
whoever the next Peter Navarro of
Trump's Administration is going to be or
a DeSantis Administration is going to be
whoever the next person is going to be
how would you use tariffs and learn from
mistakes and things we did right so if
we had another shot at negotiating with
these guys what would we be asking for
yeah and where is a pain point with them
well they'll move
well well first of all I think the best
ticket is Trump DeSantis where DeSantis
does VP for four years and then gets
eight more years and I wish that they
can come to some kind of agreement on
that and I wrote about that in my uh
taking back Trump's America book and
have urged that uh publicly okay so to
your question
um let's first of all be careful about
using
tariffs as a bargaining chip for example
China loves that right they're very
um transactional so so you you could
imagine a discussion now with Xi Jinping
and Joe Biden hey uh she says the Biden
um you you get rid of the tariffs on us
and we won't sell weapons to Russia okay
wait a minute
wait a minute that that leaves us no
better off in terms of the economy than
when we when we started
um let's understand the function of
tariffs
what we have in this world
writ large and it's just not you
mentioned Germany but it's Europe It's
Brazil it's it's India it's Vietnam we
have a world in which
virtually all of the major trading
partners charge systematically hired
tariffs
on the United States and we charge on
them so uh I just had a chapter come out
in a book that the Heritage Foundation
did which is what are the policies for
2024 for the presidential candidates and
in that I dusted off uh from the
president's State of the Union speech I
think it was in 2019 the reciprocal
trade Act Right the reciprocal trade act
simply says that hey Will
will lower our tariffs
to yours
but if you have higher tariffs than ours
and you won't lower yours then we'll
raise those to yours you think that's
effective it would be damn effective you
know who has the highest tariffs in the
world relative to us India
call it the Maharaja of tariffs but
having said that the function of tariffs
is basically to offset unfair trade
advantage okay countries in the world
they engage in in export subsidies the
vat tax versus the income tax that tax
is like a form of an export subsidy that
we that makes it very difficult China
has massive government subsidies they
steal our intellectual property they
force our technology transfer all that
the whole function of the Tariff is the
level of playing field for the American
worker now the American worker is the
most productive in the world
and can compete on a Level Playing Field
but not when other countries cheat I
mean he said all of that with communist
China it's got to be decoupling there's
no there's no modus vivendi with
communist China they want to kill us
they want this country and and you know
they they are and every which way till
Sunday you know they they inundate our
universities with sons and daughters of
the Chinese Communist party they push
our kids out and while they're there
they're wrangled by uh these Chinese
secret police so they don't go off the
reservation and what are they there for
to steal our intellectual property so
it's just
it's just we are so naive I remember
back when I got started on all this I
used to go out and do a lot of public
speaking to corporate audience before I
got canceled that's all another issue
um and I'd go talk to these trade groups
and these guys would come up and they
um grown men in tears saying hey I went
over with this great design to have it
produced in China and and by the time I
got home it was in the Walmart under
their brand no it's like yeah well how
stupid is that right it's like you just
they're playing a different game I mean
there's no there's no morals there's no
ethics there's no rules of capitalism
it's just crush us any way they can so
why would you trade with these people
why would you do that there's no reason
right now to trade with China I mean we
need they've got us you know penicillin
we need that there's certain things
we're going to need for a while but that
tells you in and of itself you need to
get off that so can I ask a quick
question on so this whole concept of
decoupling right so when Pat kind of uh
edified you at the beginning you were
Democrat or a Reagan Democrat Trump
Republican you you it seems like your
Allegiance is straight up to America
Marriott that's it America baby boom I'm
with you yes got it
um you know one of the probably the
biggest things that I've learned since
being at valuetainment my three year
anniversary is coming up by the way yeah
um congratulations thank you uh General
Spalding uh everything that we've
learned from that is really the serious
threat that China is posing to America
right so in this upcoming election you
know what you know it's the economy
stupid it's Healthcare it's immigration
it's guns it's abortion it's uh gun
control there's so many different lists
of things that are going on yeah
obviously China should be at the top of
most people's lists uh two-part question
where should China be in this list of
things that people should be considering
in the election and then part two if you
could who's against decouple at this
point who are the most vocal Advocates
of basically saying no let's continue
our relationship with China could you
explain well yeah
um so so first of all the Democrats are
going to want to run this issue on uh
abortion full stop that's it that's it
they they
arguably won
the 22 they they cut their losses
dramatically in the 2022 race
uh by making Maga a four-letter word
and by running on on Roe v Wade yeah
I've written about this where it's like
look the Supreme Court's not supposed to
be political but that's a conservative
majority how stupid are they dropping
that decision
it basically in the middle of that
elections the doves decision I mean it
was just come on yeah it's just I you
know I mean come on and and so they're
going to try to run that Playbook again
that's what they're going to do and and
they're not going to talk about coming
to shine they're just not and and
they're going to talk about Russia
Russia Russia and and you know there's a
whole nother question is what the hell
are we doing over there
um we're moving up the escalatory ladder
but for me
um what president Trump needs to run on
his Mega the Iron Triangle I talked
about you into endless Wars which has
implications for Ukraine we got a
Invasion on our Southern border and and
we're a long way from having a strong
manufacturing base will that happen I
don't think so but that's what's going
to make the American people safe
and prosperous and right now
um we're not in our political system man
is it's just it's just broken I mean
look at look at my situation I'm sure
you'll talk about it but like I I got
put in leg irons by the FBI
after being taken down at the friggin
Reagan National Airport on my way to do
an interview with Mike Huckabee I wasn't
on my way to Brazil to flee anything it
was like they're charging me with a
misdemeanor there one phone call they
could have called me up
they're putting band they're trying to
put Bannon in prison they're raiding
Mar-A-Lago they got
hundreds of people locked in DC prison
cells from the Jan six thing which which
more and more looks like an FBI
informant kind of motivated kind of
event kind of an entrapment scheme
meanwhile Hunter Biden is going free and
everybody who was involved in the Russia
hoax dating back to 2016 on the Democrat
side goes free and everybody in between
that that is a broken partisan
weaponized system but they got their
playbook down they're gonna go in and do
what they did in 2020 they're gonna I
call it the grand stuff The Ballot Box
strategy I mean to still do its Essence
it's you you you stuff that Ballot Box
with absentee ballots at the same time
you take away things like signature
match so you don't know whether those
ballots are are valid or not and you
just overwhelm a Republican party which
is too freaking stupid to understand in
that if you rely on Game Day voting
you're going to have a lower turnout
because things happen you know parents
have sick kids or they have to go to
work or whatever so this system this
political system which should be focused
on China but is going to focus instead
on things like Russia and abortion is
going to I you know my greatest fear is
that we're going to lose the one last
opportunity we have to save this country
and that's not dramatic that's not
hyperbole it's just I mean I've seen it
I mean I've lived this thing we're we're
in a stagflationary 1970s environment
threatened by communist China and you
know it's like
nobody's paying any attention to that
except the show
let me let me out and I appreciate it
kudos to that yes thank you thank you
for that and Peter question for you
those of the question you asked clear
Adam to go into that direction I want to
wrap up the conversation about tariffs I
really want to understand this tariffs
and what it does do you think how how
long do we put those strong sanctions
and tariffs on Iran what was the
timeline of that well they're still on
okay yeah and and is it still the
tariffs are irrelevant to Iran it's more
just the financial sanctions on oil
right and the thing you have to
understand about financial sanctions and
oil is oil is priced in U.S dollars and
and as long as oil is priced in the US
Dollars Iran can be hurt by that but the
problem now is we've got the Saudis
flirting with the the commas Chinese
um and agreeing to trade in Yuan which
is the Chinese currency and that that
provides an opening for Iran and the
Middle East to and you know if you if if
we stop trading worldwide oil in dollars
that has its own implications do you
think the sanctions and the and the
tariffs that we had on China on you know
Russia on Iran all these that we have do
you think that that unified them because
they all okay so so Russia China Iran
Saudi and even maybe Brazil they're all
looking at saying oh yeah let me give
you an example here because you just I
thought you were going in a slightly
different direction it's like when
Rocket Man in North Korea was given us
such a freaking hard time and the boss
wanted to break bring Rocket Man under
troll we slap sanctions on on them
um and and told the common is Chinese
you know like don't be giving them
oiled and anything like that otherwise
we're sanctioning you we didn't enforce
that stuff and we could see it you talk
about I mean I can tell you something
from the the top secret briefings
because it wound up in the New York
Times eventually
um you could see like these these uh
ships that would go out
uh you know Chinese would would send it
to Vietnam the tankers would go out in
the middle of the ocean and then they'd
switch them and then off that oil would
find its way uh to North Korea to heat
the Palace of uh Kim Jong-un well people
of North Korea starve and freeze but the
point is that
unless those sanctions are hard and
tight like a Nolan Ryan fastball all
you've done is create this alternative
currency monster which is where we're
heading now sir okay so so we can skip
that part because in my own mind I just
kind of wanted to know that some of
those tariffs maybe unified our enemies
and now they got stronger and they're
realizing you know what here's how we're
going to deal with it not the tariffs
the same sanctions separate matter it's
a totally separate matter tariffs what's
more painful
um well it depends on the country for
Iran clearly Financial sanctions right
because they don't they don't trade a
lot in other Goods right when did they
remove when we when they're they're
still on they're still on yeah there's
there's some form of sanctions still on
Iran because look if Iran gets the bomb
yeah Israel is like like maniacally and
rightly focused on making sure that Iran
doesn't doesn't get the capability of
dropping the big one because damn well
they'll use it but Iran I mean look
at the top right I I think Iran is more
dangerous than Russia far more dangerous
because you they basically you know we
went in with a stupid endless war in
Iraq and now Iran basically controls
Iraq dangerous in what regard to the
world to us yes absolutely because they
they want to kill the great Satan I mean
there's there's no question about Iran
wanting to take down the United States I
mean go back to colemany's statements
about the great state in America right
and and they uh they're they're
basically a breeding ground for for and
what I fear from China
is not nuclear weapons right now that's
not the way they're going to do it
they're going to do it through this
unrestricted warfact techniques
blockchain technology to disrupt their
financial system viruses to take out our
electric grid and other types of uh
capacity
um we haven't even talked about the the
Wuhan virus yeah I was going to say
actual viruses yeah I mean look they
learn
boy did did
the dangerous lesson from what communist
China spawned in that lab and it came
from that lab is that
the American democracy
seems extremely more vulnerable
to disruption by viruses than other
countries we just at the end of the day
you look into you could quarterback this
we just did not handle that
properly yeah and we were lied to I mean
I go off on fouchy for I mean I know if
you read read my my last book that
taking back Trump's America but there's
a scene in The Situation Room where I
first meet Tony fauci on January 28
2020. now let's frame that right January
28th 2016 24th before all the shutdowns
seven weeks before Biden just took off
yes was sworn in eight days before uh
prior no no no no no no no no no no this
is a year prior today
this is January of the election year
yeah yeah ten months before the election
yes
that would take down Trump okay okay so
I'm there
I wrote here check this out
2006 in the coming China Wars I write
that China
is likely to create a virus that will
kill Millions hmm
2006. so when that stuff started coming
in over the cable traffic
I'm I'm looking at that in December and
I it's like my antenna up right and the
boss sends me to the sit room on the
28th and he says give me the travel ban
on China we got to do that and those
people in that room are against it you
know is Mulvaney running the room he was
the chief acting chief of staff at the
time Republican Chief of Staff yes he's
chairing that meaning I walk in there I
don't know any of these people who from
outside the White House right so who's
there in that red field
from CDC
and fauci
from NIH right those are the two big
players
I go in there and within six minutes I'm
in a shouting match with that son of a
[__] and all he keeps saying is without
you with fauci I don't know who he is
okay literally I don't even know who I
didn't know who he was didn't know he
walked on water wow didn't know he
killed tens of thousands of people
during the AIDS epidemic and got away
with that's another story
um don't know who he is but you know
it's like it's like somebody walks in
here and sits down here you don't know
who he is and you start interviewing him
what do you do you take their measure
right and my measure of fauci was this
dude thinks he's a whole lot smarter
than he is and he's an arrogant son of a
[__]
this is within the first six minutes six
minutes sounds like Antonio Brown
interview and I'm you know the one one
of the things I'm good at is taking the
measure of people pretty quick the boss
is good at that too Trump
and I'm thinking what and so I fight
with this guy
Mulvaney I'm fighting with him
Redfield comes in and supports fauci and
we lead that meeting
with Mulvaney tries to say all right we
have a consensus we're against the trail
ban I said no no no no no there's no
freaking consent I just like it no no no
no Mick there are no consensus in this
room
and and pottinger finally says something
he's a National Security Council and
what I do that night as I go home and I
write a memo
that I that I'm going to plaster to the
entire Task Force and and Broad chain
that says that if we don't do this
if we don't do this this virus is
capable of killing
half a million Americans and costing us
trillions of dollars
January 28 2020 and that was that's
about as the best memo I've probably
ever written because it was spot on and
here's the punchline
fauci when he was sitting there
that SOB knew for a fact that that virus
came from the Wuhan lab he knew that
because he had funded the gain of
function research
in that lab and he had already begun to
design a cover-up and we know that from
the emails he sent to a group of of
researchers academics trying to get
their support to push that come from
nature Theory and that's the biggest
liable mission in American history
because if he had simply owned up to the
fact that that thing
came from the lab we could have
pressured the Chinese to give us the
genome sequence
which would have allowed us to design an
effective vaccine rather than the crap
we wound up getting and again Trump got
lied to about that not just by fauci but
by Pfizer the drug company in what way
they didn't disclose the side effects of
that and they weren't clear with him
they made him think that it was a true
vaccine when it's not it's mRNA
technology and yeah I I
I worked with a guy named Dr Robert
Malone you have him on the show
sometimes yeah yeah it's like the way I
I mean balloon was out there beforehand
but but I had him on Steve bannon's war
room when I was guest hosting he sat
kind of like well like you and me are
sitting Patrick and we talked about all
this and wound up writing a three-part
Series in the Washington Times about how
the universal vax policy would basically
spawn mutations
that would be more lethal
oh you don't have to get too much in
that my point is that is that that day
that January 28th day was a very
significant one overlooked in the
history of the pandemic and in American
history because fauci was there he
opposed the president's travel ban he
lied to the American people by not
disclosing right then what should have
been his his
even if he didn't know that it came from
the lab he should have told us it might
have come from the lab and because he
didn't do that we didn't get the genome
we didn't get a thing and fauci goes on
at six six a knife in the back uh of the
president throughout that election cycle
yeah you know he told the boss to fire
that SOB twice and what did you say when
you told him well the problem was
um I was a lone voice and I don't blame
him for not taking my advice in that you
know I'm like what I'm like the trade
advisor right and and he had like every
time fauci got into political trouble uh
with Trump
uh Redfield
CDC Steve Hahn the head of the FDA
um Azar the head of the Health and Human
Services
come to his rescue
and you know I would spend the next you
know I went from trades are and China
Hawk to quartermaster I was the guy for
the next nine months that would try to
make sure we all had the masks and the
PPE and the hydroxychloroquine before
they took that away and um
well I'll leave you one last thing on it
which which amuses me and and pains me
to this day you know I used to hold
these uh these weekly meetings over at
HHS the Health and Human Services
um on supply chain getting making sure
we had everything and every time I
walked in there the place was empty
empty okay this is like wartime kids get
your ass to the office I don't care if
you're putting yourself at risk that
place was a ghost town
and so anyway I did you end up taking a
vaccine yourself I did not you never
took the vaccine okay yeah so you uh got
it and and I'll you know why I'll tell
you why it uh I had the opportunity to
get the vaccine on my way out okay get
my exit medical interview with Walter
Reed right and it's like
I'm looking at the situation and you've
got
people dying
by the tens of thousands and
particularly in the African-American
Community I mean it was getting hit
really hard I'm thinking to myself
you know what what is this it's like I'm
not going to stand up in front of the
line just because I'm a White House
official no no let other folks get this
you know it's kind of like let it's like
you're the last man who leaves the ship
no no no
and then um you know once I got out
um I got I'm a hydroxychloroquine guy I
don't know if you want to go there and
it's like this we don't need to do we've
done that 50 times yeah yeah but but the
thing is
you know I it just never got there and
as as more information came out I think
this was something's been interesting
let me ask this question there's a
there's certain personalities that have
created a lot of hate and anger towards
them okay a lot yeah the left has that
towards president Trump you just have
that from day one from day one yeah and
uh uh from the day he came down the
escalator yeah you know so that's that's
that but but the the the the a lot of
people on the right and the center and
even some on the left have that for
fauci they're not fans of fauci on the
way he did a lot of things right now you
know according to Guardian I don't know
if you're aware of this or not he is the
sexiest man alive you know he's been
recognized by a lot of people make
baseball cards she's got all these other
things right it's a very good guy
according to Guardian yeah I mean Brad
Pitt's got nothing on about you but so
so but but but the but the thing here
the question the worst uh opening day
pitch ever
by anybody I don't know if you ever saw
that you've never seen 50 cents or
something no no no no no no no no no
this was the one or Obama no no no no no
no no no no no you found Jesus was the
word but plug it in yeah yeah get down
up there he should have been fired right
after that oh yeah anyway go ahead not
Nolan Ryan the question I'm asking is
the following so here's here's a
criticism when I when I'm talking to if
you want to pause it Rob because I don't
want people to be distracted I want to
sound this question we'll look at that
here in a minute yeah the the the the
questions or play it for some people
that are not getting
your judgment to see if 50. I've seen it
I've seen it go right to play it so we
can get that come on come play by the
way he's out there there we go sunlight
are you kidding me he had his mask on
give the guy with the mask that's
actually not bad he was aiming at the
camera lady so but uh but but the
question nobody told me yeah by the way
by the way you know his press
conferences go the same way yes
that's that's the sexiest man alive
right
that's according to Guardian sexiest man
alive but here's what I was going to ask
you he's going to ask you so so there's
people that are saying this man alive so
there's people that are saying hey
president Trump you said you're gonna
you're gonna you know drain the swamp
but you didn't drain the swamp Okay we
voted for you draining the swamp this is
literally the conversation that happens
when I talk to people yes you did not
drain the swamp if he was part of swan
why did you leave him there why'd you
keep him there so now there's certain
people that are sitting there the next
concern I call 2023 to your
investigations I call this in December
of last year saying this is going to be
a year where everybody's gonna be going
through investigations okay
the most viral moment of the debate in
2016 between President Trump and Clinton
Hillary Clinton was what because you'd
be in jail boom it was a most viral
moment and you know what a lot of people
said man we would love for her to
finally be held accountable nothing
happened yeah hey uh uh uh you know
Governor DeSantis said I would have
fired fauci I think he said that on the
Pierce Morgan show that he did okay now
the Anthony fauci this week when he was
being interviewed he said I think we
need to stop with this playing game and
kind of move on right yeah a person like
this that gets away with all of that yes
what can the president do say president
Trump does get elected the voters may
say one of the things we want you to do
is we want you to investigate the
origins of covet as well as things that
Anthony fauci did kind of like what we
got with Twitter files we want to find
that out can the voters get something
from president Trump to get to the
bottom of what happened with fauci yes
uh indeed look the big overarching
principle here from The Taking Back
Trump's American book which was was
quite harsh in terms of criticizing my
colleagues inside the west wing and in
the administration
the old saw of personnel is policy right
did Reagan said you get the right people
you get the right policy see well in the
Trump Administration bad Personnel was
not only bad policy it was bad politics
and there were just a lot of people that
stabbed him in the back
that had been appointed or talked him
into things that he knows now he
shouldn't shouldn't have done okay and
you talk about Hillary Clinton
the two problems we had was Jeff
sessions as A.G attorney general to doj
and then Bill Barr sessions
I love Jeff
um wasn't The Brightest Bulb on the
planet but if he had been Secretary of
DHS Homeland Security he would have been
there for four years and and served
admirably okay putting them in at the
justice department into that Shark Tank
he got immediately taken out when he
recused himself on the the Trump Russia
hoax stuff and that left inside the
career bureaucrats to deal with the
issue and it never got dealt with right
and then Bill Barr comes along he's a
he's a white shoe globalist Republican
who you know when the boss appointed him
I just like said to myself
why that this will end badly and it did
and Barr
um for example the worst thing Barr did
that that actually cost Trump the
election and it did cost in the election
was not
prosecute swiftly the information on the
hunter Biden laptop from hell I know if
you know this but they had Bill Barr had
that laptop over a year before the
election
and they just sat on that and and and we
know now that that laptop was real that
what's in it implicates by at Hunter
Biden and and and in all likelihood the
big guy Joe Biden in all sorts of 10 for
the big yeah yeah I mean it's like so
and and the Trump trump Administration
was riddled
with people like that when In The West
Wing the guys I always had to fight on
the trade issue was first Gary Cohn the
Goldman Sachs New York liberal Democrat
why is he there
uh to support Wall Street and then and
then Kudlow
um who replaced him and then Steve
mnuchin another kind of so my point is
that
the second time will be different I am
convinced of that at the end he had the
boss had Johnny mcentee
running personnel and and I can think of
nobody better than Johnny mcentee to
make sure that the people who go in are
Trump people and that they know what to
do and the beauty of a second term is
that the learning curve that's why the
santis would not be a good good
immediate choice there's a big learning
curve so we're in the white house we
have to learn from 2020 okay and based
on your books taking back Trump's
America why we lost the White House and
how we will win it back I'm going to
read a couple things from your book and
I want to get your reaction to it so
during the home stretch of the 2020
election President Trump was rocked by
one the worst presidential campaigns in
modern history you're saying this that's
your claim they ran effectively one of
the worst presidential campaigns in
modern history with star con contrast to
his 2016 the president himself I think
did a wonderful job leading the country
he had a vision but he frankly was let
down by bad Personnel that got inside
the west wing and never should have
Navarre told the Washington examiner
Monday at a cocktail and press event for
his new book taking back Trump's why we
lost the White House and then you
continue but in Navarro's mind the
election should have been a landslide
that they would have likely eclipsed any
potential fraud campaign uh ineptness uh
morphed Trump's Showdown with Biden into
something far closer than it otherwise
would have been and then you continue to
talk about you know the West Wing
dumpster he has a long lamented that the
Trump Administration was stacked with
poor personal choices such as former
chief economic adviser Gary Cohen former
treasury secretary Steve
mnuchin and former Chief of Staff John
Kelly
and then last but not least there was
one man in particular whose involvement
particularly PIV Navarro Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner in 2016 we were
significantly outspent by but the money
was used wisely and in 2020 we had
plenty of money but Kushner Burton like
monkey with a flamethrower and when push
came to shove in final six weeks of the
campaign we ran out of money Navara said
there were young kids over there making
six figures and then when the pandemic
hit they didn't even work come to work
while Brad Pascal was the chief of the
floundering Trump campaign on paper
Navara dubs Kushner as the de facto
campaign manager responsible for much of
the campaign's chaos in his book slated
for release Tuesday he alleged that
Kushner frequently added points to the
polls and lied to the boss eventually
Navarro and his allies backed by Donald
Trump Jr concocted an unsuccessful coup
d'etat of sorts of oust Kushner from his
campaign perch according to the book The
Navara Kushner was part of a larger
problem in the White House
fueling much of Trump's woes was the
reapproachment with the traditional
Republicans the former president
pursuing pursued during his early White
House days so I mean this is a direct
call out of Kushner yeah okay yeah
direct call out this is a son-in-law
this is married to his daughter and this
is a guy that was on the cover of Time
Magazine family business you know all
the great things he's doing he's about
20 minutes from here yeah he is setting
up a a money fund and and leveraging his
experience such as it was in the White
House making a ton of money
Middle East maybe China
um and it was a business to him and look
if you talk about the campaign itself
I'll give you a couple of examples
Zuckerberg at Facebook
spent more money
in the Battleground states where this
election was settled then the Trump
campaign did think about that Zuckerberg
alone
spent more money
you talking about the 400 million
it's a bit more than that last time I
looked it was it was more than that more
like 800 million it's a bunch of money
and we we didn't
look you talked about me early on
running for office kind of the one
mistake I made I ran from mayor of San
Diego 92. lost by any percentage point
maybe a percentage point and a half okay
the big mistake I made was I spent my
money early okay all I need had to do
was win that race was wait till the last
three to four weeks and spend my money
then when people were paying attention
we blew
10 10 million dollar Super Bowl ads for
60 seconds and when when the last
three to four weeks of the campaign we
had to pull ads from the Battleground
States and Biden outspent Us in the
Battleground States on ads when when we
outraged them and this this shouldn't
happen but the bigger problem Patrick
was the messaging itself you know the
message should have been
tough on China
it should have been tough on China and I
had a beautiful one of the things I
learned it's like you know I go in there
and I'm kind of a Rube when I first get
there and they try to bury me and it's
that's all chronicled in uh in my in
Trump time book where they they try to
marginalize me I've been on the campaign
I've been the top economic advisor and
when I get there
the the reince priebus the chief of
staff and kind of the Rhino Wing they
try to just bury me over in the EOB so
what I did was dig in and learn how how
power works in the White House and the
the instrument of power in the White
House is the executive order and
presidential memorandum and I learned
how to write those things
and
I I think I had more hands and more EOS
than any other person in the West Wing
when the when the dust settled but the
one that got away from me that would
have swung the election
and it should be passed today in
Congress was an executive order that
would have held communist China to
account for the virus it called for
investigating communist China's role in
the virus and estimating the costs
um of that virus on the U.S economy
demanding reparations and basically just
airing this whole thing out
and I got within a whisker of getting
the boss on board with that he liked it
initially but he got talked out of it by
the likes of Kushner at all
um who didn't want to rock the China
boat they thought oh it's like now we
can't do that now but that that would
have shifted the blame
for the pandemic from Trump's shoulders
which was there
unfairly
to where it belonged to come as China
and that one got away and that's to me
the ultimate failure
of the the Trump campaign we ran we
forgot who we were we were we're Mega
and we're tough on China we forgot that
and we lost so with the election coming
up Peter you've got the American people
were hurting on two sides one we were
hurting socially because we got the
virus we got you know vaccines people we
know were passing away uh that's real it
was very real very real but then we also
had economic impact you know we see what
happened to credit card debt that was
later bailed out by the uh by the by the
uh trillions dollars of printing money
and stimulus so you're saying at that
time just being tough on China would
have swung the election that seems like
a broad statement with a lot going on
with the American voters yeah okay let's
when was this let's put the date January
28 2020 you're very specific about that
when would you have implemented this
tough on China at what point was that
when you when they said no we're not
going to do this so we can kind of see
the mind and the ramp you're very
specific and you're very convincing show
us the ramp into the election from that
day okay let's let's first first make
the case that
in January 2020 Trump was a lock for
reelection at that point I think that
the strength of the economy I don't
think anybody with the people nobody
would know that we all remember
the NBA player Mark Cuban on camera the
NHL panics and cancels it yeah 72 hours
in February it's probably a book someday
72 hours in February where life changed
for us prior to that 100 agreement yeah
and and and just a little side note
um I was in the Oval Office with the
president with Kudlow with mnuchin with
others Mulvaney
um in early February before all this
fell apart and they're they're going
like don't worry about the virus it's no
big deal we got it under control right
it's like there's only four levels goes
there's only four cases and I'm thinking
dude you don't understand logarithmic
progression you know it's four today
eight tomorrow
um and
one of the problems we had was we we
didn't signal that we were taking the
virus seriously early
and through the combination of of you
know fauci became the voice of the
administration uh Trump became the guy
that the American people held
responsible for everybody dying and yeah
we did some great things I I got some
great tales in the book about getting
um his cotton swabs over from a plant in
Italy in three days after commandeering
uh Pentagon planes in the cooperation of
FedEx I mean we were like we did as well
as we can but but we didn't Market it
well so my point is that talk about the
first chapters of operation warp speed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and my point is
that is that the virus
just just everybody blamed Trump okay
let's let's agree that the American
people blame Trump for the virus I think
that's for the for not handling the
virus well all right so that was the
problem we were dealing with the diet
the
conversation about the election
um and driven by CNN and MSNBC with
their body counts to a certain extent
Fox was that this is the major issue and
Trump's to blame I think that's was the
sentiment of the country and it's like
wait a minute it's like
we're doing a good job if we could get
that message out but more importantly
this isn't Trump's fall this is the a
virus from a lab in Wuhan that's being
hit so my thinking was that if we could
air that out that would that would
basically and we were going to drop the
report okay the preliminary report the
EO was written we dropped the
preliminary report in the first week in
October and that report and it would be
from a group of very distinguished
people you know you look at the data
it's on it it's like there's no doubt
that thing came from the lab and that
would have I think I think that would
have
helped with that one issue it would have
changed changed the dialogue on that but
that one got away
you talked you talked about the the
number of people uh on the campaign
specifically Kushner when you're talking
about during that time in 2016 Brad
Pascal was the digital media director
and then I think in 2020 he became the
campaign manager yeah in 2016 I recall
him being a star everybody was talking
about look what a great job he did but
then you're criticizing them for 2020 on
what he did so what was different about
Brad in 2016 versus 2020 with a strategy
what per scale did well was handled
digital media he wasn't running a
campaign mind you okay running a
campaign
is a very complex task across 50 states
I mean you got to do all sorts of stuff
and what he did was one
important bucket out of a hundred
and
the the two worst mistakes that parscale
made it was the same mistake in a way
was when he got on 60 minutes after the
2016 election and effectively not only
claim credit for the win you know was
him not Trump that won the election
because of his genius
but he also revealed that he had
recruited uh Facebook
employees and I think Twitter employees
actually work inside the campaign to
help them managing their messages on the
social welfare platforms okay what did
that do that was like a wake up I write
about this in in the in Trump time but
that's like a wake-up call to Silicon
Valley it's like Zuckerberg's getting
hate mail dorsey's getting ahead now how
could you lie in bed and make a bunch of
money from Trump and Par scale basically
planted the seeds of Zuckerberg's
counter-offensive in the 2020 campaign
look Brad
Brad's a good guy he's a nice guy but
he's a
Geeks
he sits yeah he's again it's like when
the pandemic hit it was a blessing for
him because oh he could go back to what
he did in 2016. they're very important
what what what he did in 2016 was
sitting in San Antonio most of the time
in front of his computer and like this
time when the pandemic hit he was down
here in Miami
significantly richer would like a big
boat and seven cars he didn't even come
very often up to Arlington to the
campaign you can't do that look look
it's like I the analogy I used was like
putting a plate a champion Place kicker
in it quarterback okay he was a great
place kicker in 2016. okay he could hit
the uprights from 60 yards
and in 2020 you can't put him in the
Super Bowl that's the Super Bowl guys
that's the Super Bowl he wasn't Tom
Brady axios uh July 20th 2020 story 2022
story Navarro's dream cabinet for
potential second term run Navarro
hardcore Trump loyalist gives axios an
exclusive look at the passage containing
potential choices for second term
cabinet form his uh forthcoming book
taking Trump back uh taking back Trump's
America some old gang choices for 2025.
former Trump National Security adviser
Robert O'Brien for Secretary of State
Ben Carson to HHS Bob uh light instead
of instead of the urban yeah
yeah which was like come on give me a
break here by the way if Carson had been
there when the pandemic hit we would
have been a lot better off go ahead I I
I I think a lot of people agree Bob uh
light uh uh light teaser lighthizer
lighthizer to Commerce a cash Patel to
Director of National Intelligence John
Ratcliffe to CI director
Ken kuchellini returning as head of
Homeland Security oh he went over to the
DeSantis card so I gotta rethink that
but go ahead Dan uh bralette in second
term of energy Linda McMahon yeah David
Barnhart in second term of interior and
for New Blood with strong Trump loyal
tiles judge Jean Janine Piro of Fox News
attorney general some say she may not
have a job for too long with time her
and uh uh uh what's her name um
bartaroma yep that's the name of that
spin but go ahead okay former
Congressman Sean Duffy to ahead
Transportation love him Bill Gertz uh
for dni or CIA Oracle CEO Safra uh uh
Katz or Laura Trump as U.N Ambassador
and Mike colesbury Frank Gaffney and
Brian Kennedy as ambassador to China
nails so any other names you would say
um that and by the way this is this is
for the cabinet right now for him to win
West Wing right for fright enough for
him to win 2024 do you think he has the
right people on his team today to win
2024. uh yeah so far yeah but but but
it's early in the campaign and there's a
lot of Demands on President Trump now
one of the things that really worries me
is he's got this think tank it's not his
but it's they're using his name to raise
a bunch of money it's run by
um Brooke Rollins who was a good friend
of Ivanka and ran uh the domestic policy
Council in the final months
and
half of the people are more at that
think tank or never trumpers and
documentingly so it's like what what the
hell's going on there's just a lot of
people measuring the drapes now on the
outside and
um you know I'm my counsel to the bus
over and over is going to be you know
your most important decisions will be
Personnel initially and we can't we
can't let history repeat itself there
what what would you say were you know
you always here if you work for
president Trump loyalties at the top
right it's very important to be loyal to
him what other things you think he
values to get people on the inside well
he doesn't suffer fools gladly I mean
look if if you got to have you gotta
have the smarts and the Loyalty that's
that's the combo
um
and um he's a very
some of the great greatest times I had
in the Oval Office
um were were when we were debating
complex policy issues or in the
Roosevelt room
um with
group groups of top advisors where he'd
go around the room and listen and you
know if if if somebody started saying
something that
that wasn't smart he'd cut them off or
if he yeah he is an eerie way of
finishing your thought you can see kind
of he moves things along but um
in 2016 after he won there wasn't a lot
of developed Talent at that point
because nobody thought he was going to
be able to run and there was some some
problems we had early
uh that paved the way for uh
um rhinos to get into positions of power
I mean I I like rides now and by the
time reince got fired he was on the
Trump train but when he first came in
um he he wanted no part no part of
anything related to getting tough on
trade he was strict Paul Ryan Wisconsin
Republican they just wanted to pass a
tax bill uh and repeal Obamacare they
talked the boss into that and it was a
it was a disaster because they couldn't
deliver the vote so the point is bad
personnel
um is bad policy and I would be remiss
here I've been I've been good about not
mentioning this but let me just say that
you know I'm canceled right I appreciate
you having me on your show but I'm
canceled on places where I used to go
normally like CNN MSNBC
um Fox News
and what I've discovered and this is why
this is a great entrepreneur's show
there's this thing this this sub stack
thing that
um has enabled me to speak directly to
people in a way which helps me raise
money also for my legal defense fund is
it's a million dollar fight I'm in but
it's Peter
navarro.substack.com Peter
navarro.substack.com and what I'm trying
to do with the sub stack is is about
three times a week I'm putting out op-ed
length missives on issues related to
communist China
um the economy and the financial markets
which which speak to my strength is a
macro Economist in my Harvard PhD
um things related to fauci and then just
all things Trump 2020 we have a link
we've posted it four or five times
already yeah I appreciate people to go
again that's a question on the Personnel
sure
um we're talking about Trump's Personnel
yes and for the audience yes brace for
impact you may or may not like the
question but this is a direct question
to you you know Trump Prides himself on
hiring the best he's like I do the best
I hire the best you know The Apprentice
you know you're fine all that all that
so you know I had a conversation one
time with former Chief of Staff General
John Kelly and we had a cocktail we were
at a financial conference he was the
guest speaker and I candidly asked him a
question I said what do you enjoy the
most about working for president Trump
and what what did you least enjoy the
most or what was your biggest issue with
them and he goes my biggest problem
what president Trump was that he was not
willing to listen to experts this is his
former Chief of Staff General John Kelly
telling me this is what he's saying okay
um we just went down the list Gary Cohen
um Mick Mulvaney General Mattis uh
General Kelly Bill Barr you said it was
potentially a bad hire uh even Mike
Pence at this point is not exactly in
best favor with Trump although I think
he was a very loyal Vice President John
Bolton not exactly a fan
um if Trump is elected again yes what
how much should he actually listen to
experts and how much should he go with
his gut like you even gave the example
of you think that fauci lied to him
right who he keeps around him so if
you're Trump you know that at the time
right well you never know if someone's
lying to you up front like you kind of
find out in the end but yeah to be clear
yeah uh if Trump gets elected again how
much should he trust the advisers around
him who should we just went through this
list versus just kind of go with his gut
and do it by him himself what do you
recommend so
um I had an interesting relationship
um with John Kelly
I admire a man who puts on a uniform and
puts his life at risk out in places like
Afghan like Afghanistan and has a and
and basically
sacrifices one of his sons to that war
because he lost his son there
um
Kelly
was not Suited
for being Chief of Staff in the Trump
White House he should have stayed at the
Department of Homeland Security he
understood border security and National
Security issues and he would have done a
good job there but when Kelly came in
he committed the the Corey Lewandowski
Dave bossi ultimate sin was he didn't
understand to let Trump beat Trump and
letting Trump be Trump means actually
being able to listen
not just to experts but to everybody and
what Donald Trump loves to do every day
you know he's got the discipline he's
the hardest working man in Show Business
trust me on that
um what he loves to do every day is scan
all of the media right he reads
everything he's watching TV picking up
all that and then he's on the phone
most of the day or he's got in-person
meetings with people asking them about
issues and he values
people in the streets opinions as much
as he does some of the so-called experts
and so what Kelly says that
what Kelly means is that he wouldn't
listen to some of his advisors who we
figured out pretty early on didn't
weren't on the Trump train
um and Kelly wouldn't let him
listen to others I mean Kelly used to
eavesdrop on conversations
and see the boss what the boss would do
at night you know if you wanted to talk
to the boss and I had to do this a
number of times it's like it's like
Kelly won't let you talk to him so I
just called him a night right you know
it's like and then the next day it's
like Kelly what'd you call the boss for
he said I had to talk to him because I
almost said I'm an assistant of the
president I'm a highest rank I don't
report to you I report that you have
that conversation but the point is that
um that's a bad rap that's just wrong
and Kelly's mistake when he came in is
he fell in
with the wrong people particularly on
the trade issue I mean he went right
with mnuchin and Cohn and Rob Porter the
staff secretary office and they did
everything possible with Kelly helping
him to stop the stealing the lunar
terrorists to stop the China tariffs and
and the boss like looks up like six
months later he goes you know where's my
peter that was his rallying right he
pulls me in there's a famous scene in
the book about how I'd go in there mono
imano with Gary Cohn and it's like it's
like the boss finally says no we're
going to do this and and we did it and
then shortly thereafter cones out the
friggin door but that was Kelly's fault
because Kelly
tried to wall the boss off and and wall
people like me off who supported the
Trump stuff
which he viewed frankly is dangerous and
he he went with the the the regular line
and you know that's the sad thing was
there's a there's a poignant Moment In
the book where we're sitting in Buenos
Aires Argentina and it's like one of
Kelly's last days you know he's out the
door he's sitting right by me and he
apologizes and he basically says you
know it's like
you were one of the good guys and I'm
sorry I didn't get that right and I said
you know John that's cool man we're good
quick follow-up
um I totally appreciate having uh people
that are on your team on the Trump train
certainly in your cabinet but not think
offense smartphone that was my question
willing like I argue with the boss as
much as I agree with right okay be it's
like I'll go in and tell them
sell them stuff that he might not want
to hear but he respects that he respects
that that's why I was able to stay so
long because he knew when I came in
there and told him stuff I wasn't
bullshitting around I just looked him in
the eye this is what I think
right and so yeah I guess how do you not
uh insulate yourself with yes men versus
people who are on your team but will
also give you critical feedback when
you're not making money you don't set
out he dopes that out quickly yeah I
mean he was like he gets these people in
there and then he's stuck I mean Mattis
Mattis that guy he sets up look again
he's a general you get you admire his
service in the field but he wasn't he
wasn't trained to run the Pentagon he
goes over there and he walls himself off
um he won't he won't accept the
appointments of anybody we send over to
him
instead he wants to put in a bunch of
liberal Democrat folks
and the biggest thing that that I fought
him on was in order to get steel and
aluminum terrorist past which and we
need to steal an aluminum Industries in
this country
um we had to have buy-in from the SEC
death the Secretary of Defense on the
Department of Commerce Secretary of
Commerce Wilbur Ross's effort and he
fought us on that and the boss is going
I remember there's a this is announced
this did not turn out well for me over
time because I took I would take a lot
of heat from these guys but he brings me
up boss brings me into the oval and he's
got Madison Rex Tillerson there the
Secretary of State yeah and he's all
these names it's like the greatest hits
I've ever seen his names he's gone he's
going he looks and Rex was outgunned by
the position from day one yes but but
but he goes he goes Peter tell these
guys
why we needed to put tariffs on South
Korea please and renegotiate that deal
would you tell me that please and it was
like it's like guys it's like National
Security is economic security Economic
Security is National Security if we keep
letting the Koreans
get away with all the unfair trade and
putting our pickup truck industry and
our Auto industry out of business we're
not going to have the plants or the
government revenues to make your tanks
and planes
and and by the way Rex uh we're not
going to have the status as a superpower
if we're diminished by that that's those
guys those guys
um I've got a someday I gotta publish
this this thing it's just a short letter
from Kelly to me the chief of staff
Kelly when I was I was like
um as as a White House
advisor I was in charge of of foreign
arms sales okay they were like dragons
so the idea is that if we can sell f-16s
to Bosnia right that's a good deal for
the American people because it creates
jobs and it also
outsources some of our defense
obligations like we don't have to be
there they'll do it for us and and
Madison's office was it was give me hard
times I can't kind of like the next
thing I know I get a I get this email
from Kelly it's like well stop Navarro
oh what was it what the hell do you
think you're doing General Mattis beside
me that and it's a cc too what the hell
did you think you were doing I was doing
Trump's Trump's desire because he had
told me to get those foreign arm sales
going and that's the job of a White
House advisor by the way John to use the
power of the White House to move the
Trump agenda and I looked at that and I
was like yeah [__] yeah it's like and I
just kept doing what I was doing and it
but but but that's the kind of that's
the kind of dynamic in there that that
you know it's like let's transition into
a couple others sure that was very
helpful let's we got a few more minutes
I want to do a couple stories so
um by the way yeah no we're having
you're fired up right yeah you guys have
some fun on this show and you haven't
even had any chocolate
oh I I had a few few bits before I got
in you said that Darkness
it's a long slow burn it's nice it keeps
you we'll get your chocolate after this
uh so so Abby grossberg okay Abby
grossberg uh uh who
um she works at Fox she was working
under Tucker I think at one point she
was their senior Booker I don't think
her and Tucker have ever met she
criticized this Tucker what the
environment's like they don't care about
telling the truth and they don't care
about woman this is what she said of Fox
News all they care about is ratings and
revenue right that's her now the
exchange came about where your uh Ari
melber I think eight days ago you've
been on already multiple you guys have
had some good exchanges together and he
shares a recording and here's what he
says I want to get your thoughts on this
so so recording February 27 2021 you say
Trump also has to clean up the people
who surrounded him in the final days of
administration and who are crowding him
now at Mar-A-Lago uh like tens of
millions of dollars left in the campaign
that they didn't spend in time to
challenge the election issues and oh
that was criminal Abby grossberg says
what happened to all that money Navarro
well not there now they're going to I'm
going to name names
Bill State stadium
Justin Clark are the campaign guys now
that they'll go on the payroll and
they'll spend that money and it'll go
right into their pockets Brad parskill
uh might get some of that as well it's
crazy so one thing we're learning about
Abby if you're ever talking to her just
assume there's a recording if she's
recording the conversation okay but what
happens
because I I as much as I like Abby and I
I interacted with her only when she was
part of Romo's producer before she got
with Tucker is she trusted is she good
at what the idea she's very good at what
she does
um and and I can talk a lot about how
the problem at Fox but let me just say
that she had no business recording me
that that without telling me that that's
yeah I I and by the way I don't mind
yeah when I say something
I I consider it to be on the record okay
these reporters say well you wanna do
background no no it's like here it is
I'm just I'll tell you that but um I
think what's interesting about Abby
grossberg and my interactions with her
um as a frequent guest on bartiromo's
Sunday show was was kind of the the
progression of my cancellation from Fox
you know when I first got out of the
White House I I would go on Bartiromo
show like I did when I was in the white
house it was like like no big deal but
but what what would happen afterwards
it's like
Abby would put me in Maria would want me
on and some other producer somewhere who
should have had no business intervening
would say now he can't do that or he
can't talk about this there was one case
and this is breaking a little news where
I actually recorded a segment I think it
was on fauci
um and it was I mean if you play that
today it was like Fidelity I mean it was
just so spot on but for whatever reason
it was too hot to handle they canceled
it they took it out of the lineup and
they did it at such a late date because
they they taped the show and then they
put it together just before air time
that they had like a gap kind of at the
end from it
um but what that tells me is that that
the sensors at Fox were the never Trump
wing of the Fox News Network which is
which is large and larger now was
already beginning to work their magic
and Abby was was caught in that because
she was trying to do
legitimate
hard-hitting news that would appeal to
the fox viewer
and she wasn't being allowed to do that
I don't know what happened with the
Tucker stuff I I love Tucker I don't
want to get in the middle of that but I
do know when she was working for
Bartiromo the Fox News producers
with orders from uh the second floor
that's what they'd always say it was
from the second floor who's that that's
Suzanne Scott
who runs the network in Lawrence
powerful person in media Suzanne Scott
and Lauren Patterson don't don't count
her out she is uh she is uh more of a
snake than Suzanne is Suzanne's Suzanne
will tell you to your face Lauren will
just stab you in the back
so numbers came out Fox News first week
viewership dropped 29.6 percent first
week dropped 29. since the firing of
Tucker since the firing of Tucker 29.6 a
lot of numbers right there yeah after
paying 750 million dollars 787 787 yeah
so so so on top of that you have to find
that you're you're being paid Joe
Biden's writer writes one of the best
jokes where he's at the the White House
then whatever correspondence centers
well you know there's a lot of NBCS here
that owns MSNBC and you know dominions
here that owns Fox News and that's a
good joke that he says and you know
great job to the writer and you have to
tell those jokes these are jokes that
you have to say with what happened what
are your thoughts one with what's going
on at Fox
and as well as uh any thoughts you may
have with Tucker not not related to Abby
just Tucker himself
well again a little breaking news for
your show
um
in terms of my cancellation with Tucker
I I was on Tucker every once in a while
he doesn't you know but
um he had scheduled me twice
to come down to his Florida Fox Nation
Studio to do the hour-long special got a
lot kind of like this and both times
those got canceled
and uh at the time I I was
I was wondering whether it was part of
the broader cancellation of fox
um but now I'm sure that so I'm kind of
wondering
how he let that happen in some sense I
mean I got pulled on my way to the the
video truck from Janine's show twice so
so I think Tucker I I think Tucker was
was really pissed off
at the restraints that Fox was trying to
put on him and I think
that probably led him to to even fight
harder for what he wanted to say which
which kind of escalated the whole thing
but but look Fox I think Fox will be
just more than happy to let Fox News
kind of fade sorta into the sunset
they'll have like a steady thing cable
TV is I mean this is the future right
here right it's it's a streaming model
uh the fox audience demo is is a is a
cable news very old demographically it's
like the Chinese population is it's you
know it's it's kind of not literally
dying off
and they'll make all their money off Fox
Sports which is a which is a bonanza and
Fox Entertainment all the other kind of
stuff they do but
the politics of Fox News are it's quite
quite simple you have
um the never Trump traditional Rhino
Republican and name only Wing in control
of the network right now with the help
of Lachlan and James Murdock who are
effectively Democrats
Roger Ailes is gone so he no longer
pleases that
and fox
is never Trump and and adopts that
Persona strictly for business purposes
that's where the money is that's where
the the Wall Street globalist money
uh the Pfizer money that runs all the
big farmer ads and they just as soon
have Trump
go away so they stop televising his
rallies they don't have him on very
often surrogates like me Rudy
Mike Flynn Don Jr you know it's like
we're we're persona non grotta Laura
Trump left there and I think it's
important you know look like I urge
people now to cut the cord there's
there's a frequent guest host and on
Steve bannon's War Room pandemic uh
there's there's Newsmax which is just up
the road from here there's the uh one uh
America News Network
um and then there's just a wealth of
podcasts out there that uh you know the
the real America's voice which is the
one bannon's on also has like the Young
Generation Charlie Kirk John Solomon
um at six with kind of the inside scoop
so my point is that that don't watch Fox
and you they're they're lying to you
that they're lying to you until they
change their ways there's no reason to
watch Fox Tucker was pretty much the
only reason why Fox is lying to you oh
yes yes so so let's define that Hannity
the whole election issue they they
bullied Hannity and Laura Ingram into
kind of like oh it's like leave it alone
let's look at the net that was the spin
that all came from the second floor came
from the Murdoch's
um but the but the LIE look Fox will
still throw red meat on the traditional
issues but at the end of the day they're
not going to tell you the truth about
everything from from communist China the
real truth to the Jan 6 to November 3rd
and any of that they're just not and and
you know the Karl roves I mean you look
at Karl Rove right he's like he's like
the most powerful person on the air and
Paul Ryan the ex-speaker of the house on
the board of directors is the most
powerful person at Fox off the air
besides the the Family itself so do you
think do you think do you think Fox and
Murdoch's there's a lot of talk they're
like oh we're gonna they're gonna
silence uh Tucker the next 18 months and
they're going to keep paying them on the
contract and they're not going to
release him because they're worried he's
going to be able to influence the
election a lot so they're going to have
to silence him there do you think if
let's just say that that theory is
correct do you think Fox and Murdoch's
are for
DeSantis to help anybody but Trump so
but is it anybody but Trump yes or is it
a liberal then DeSantis then Trump no no
it's it's anybody about Trump DeSantis
look
Maga right at the first and foremost
what Maga is is the strong American
manufacturer base achieved by being
Savvy and tough in the international
global trading Arena DeSantis has no
experience in that so he's and he's
getting a lot of big money from from The
Steve schwartzman's now Larry Finks of
this world who own Wall Street and all
the hedge fund money who make all their
money from that so it's anybody
but Trump and and that's that's the way
the coverage is going to go I mean I
look at uh I look at for example
um uh the Sunday show on Fox you know
they have ASA Hutchinson on these are
the guys like Poland at less than one
percent they give them a platform but
but to your point uh about Tucker you
know what's their strategy yeah I was on
Eric bowling last night bowling is a
former Fox Alum who got the same
treatment Tucker's getting you know he
pushed him out the door and then the
next thing you know they're leaking all
sorts of [__] to try to but pardon me
there the reputation stuff and here's
here's the strategy with Tucker it's
very simple what they're going to do
with Tucker they're going to keep him on
the payroll
for a for a while until a couple of
things happen one is that he signs the
non-disclosure agreement
so he won't be dumping on Fox when he
leaves okay that's one of the things
they'd like to get and in the meantime
they're going to use the leak machine to
degrade his brand so that his his
options will be less whatever they are
now they'll be less by the time he gets
out and if you don't believe me just
look at the Lou Dobbs model that's what
they did with Lou Lou was the Tucker of
Fox Business okay he was the guy with
the highest ratings on Fox Business
Tucker's eyes guy with the highest rate
in Fox News what they did with Lou now
he was a sacrificial lamb they fired him
they kept him on the payroll I think it
was for over a year
and now he's you know he's doing a
podcast and he you know he's I love Lou
but he's you know struggling to stay in
the top 100. they degraded his brand and
so that's the strategy and and the only
issue with Lou Dobbs is what almost 80
Tuckers in his early 50s he's not
talking about right now what he's saying
is what they did to him right after yeah
that was a few years ago yeah but it's
the same personality he's talking about
contract strategy yeah yes I get it but
Tucker's a fighter whereas Lou Dobbs is
a little bit older it's it's going to be
harder to silence someone that's way
more mainstream than Luke and what was
Lou's sin patriotism yeah I mean Tucker
look Tucker's you you write on Tucker is
a bigger bigger performance because
you're talking about his 77 you know
Tucker's 53 or 54. yeah we do respect to
Lou Dobbs I watched Fox Business all the
time Charles Payne and Neil Cavuto I
think they're great bartiroma Tucker's
way bigger than Lou dubs no no I'm just
saying yeah
what if somebody offers to buy Tucker's
current remaining contract with Fox
release them and selling no they they
did look the big thing is the
non-disclosure okay they don't want
Tucker going off and and talking about
the inner workings of fox it goes he
goes over to like I don't know Newsmax
or one America's news uh those things
like immediately they their whole
viewership jumps dramatically real
America's voice brings him in I mean
they don't
they have to
they have to shut him down they have to
keep him quiet you know that's what they
do if you look at what they did with
Megyn Kelly whoever it's like they get
them they force them to sign
non-disclosure deals and they leak
that's the big thing they're leaking all
sorts of stuff right now to kind of make
Tucker a little certain stories you know
whatever yeah they do the same thing
that Trump gets he's a misogynist he's a
racist he's in this he said that you
can't believe any of that there's a
Playbook here as well yeah there's a
Playbook and they're following the
Playbook it's just business and it's
scurrilous business it's Business
Without ethics or morals and that's why
I say the people who watch Fox News
cannot trust Fox news to tell them the
truth
well isn't that politics in general
Business Without morals and ethics
that's just I mean that's probably yeah
but it's when did politics become the
same principles for journalism okay well
the last time I looked it's called Fox
News it's not called Fox propaganda
although it should be well right yeah
well we can have a whole two-hour
podcast about that and CNN I got two
chapters in the in the uh taking back
Trump's America book on the uh the Fall
From Grace of the fourth estate but you
know I mean I it's like we're Ari
Fleischer I wrote a whole book about
that he was here a handful of months ago
and said exactly that yes and and
I mentioned Ari in my taking back
Trump's America book because one of the
problems we had early on was we lost the
guy who would have been a good press
secretary and Jason Miller to his own
kind of personal troubles and then we
had a succession of people that never
met the standard of of the Airy
fleischers of this world or Pierre
salinger's
um or you know some of those uh really
good press secretaries who could handle
the media we we just got handled but
that's another story
I don't know we're gonna see what's
going to happen there I mean obviously
you know there is a massive need for
something right now and if they're not
going to release the guy because they're
trying to hurt him the next 18 months
and
spread all these rumors the text the
white man you saw what they said about
you know Tucker's exchange was that how
white men fight and all this other stuff
I I don't know if it's gonna work and I
think it could potentially also backfire
on them but we will see we're gonna see
what's gonna happen Tom what is going on
with the economy I know yesterday Powell
said he increased the rates by a quarter
of a basis point what what do you know
about what's going on right now well we
have an economist in the house so maybe
we talk about the economy and talk about
the FED yesterday well as we like to say
in this program
um drum pal did what he said he was
going to do he head upstairs and saw the
cheerleader and pounded the economy for
another quarter point however in his
comments the comments that Jerome Powell
made everyone was expecting him to have
a very everybody reads the statements of
the fed and we were looking for
moderated statement and after this I
anticipate maybe a flat summer there and
he starts talking about man
Manufacturing in mid-year instead he
said you know I got to watch this
economy because
you know like training a dog
um there may be more firming necessary
and when he said the word more firming
necessary in his comments everybody Wall
Street got nervous you saw the whole
banking sector yesterday it wasn't just
First Republic contagion it was
concerned that he used more firming may
be necessary which means in June they
think rates may go up so what's going on
right now the most likely scenario and
I'm gonna I'm gonna go out and and say
this so this is what I think pbd
everything I've looked at I don't think
we're going to see a rate increase in
June I don't think we're going to see it
in uh July because it's every six weeks
folks that the FED gets together with
their Board of Governors Naomi and I
don't think there's going to be a rate
increase then we get all the way down
deep into
um September but what I do think is we
are and 88 of the analysts on Wall
Street believe we're going to have a
mild recession that is evident in the
November time frame that will push the
fed's hand and I believe in December
you'll get your quarter point drop
because they'll want to put liquidity
into the economy because combination of
unemployment and
um a a defined recession and
unemployment usually goes with recession
because people are not employed not
buying stuff which um pulls back GDP uh
I think that's what's going on I think
we're about to have a flat summer but we
did not get the enthusiasm about tamed
inflation that we thought we were going
to get from Jay Powell and he put the
next quarter point on there and it's not
going to help the housing market it's
not going to help mortgages and it's not
going to help business liquidity there's
a big credit crunch right now and and
Commercial Real Estate is in deep
trouble what do you say about that what
are your thoughts hey Rob Rob do me a
favor see if you pull up like Bloomberg
and see what right now what the s p is
doing whether it's up or down and
because SMP is down
um
yeah yeah yeah so so yesterday it it
right after so my joke is that the the
bay the way to be able to afford a house
in Palm Beach over the last I don't know
ever since Powell got appointed was to
uh short the stock market whenever he
got on the podium and there's been only
one time when Jim Rome Powell has got on
the podium where the stock stocks went
up because even if he's got like good
news right he he can't he can't he's
like selling Sushi like raw fish right
so the guy
um you know it just doesn't make it but
but but what you've just laid out is is
kind of I think that's like um hope is
not a strategy it's the Mike Tyson thing
that that you've got a plan uh
until you take the first punch in the
face and we got we got punches coming at
us see here's the way here's the one
thing I can I can tell tell your viewers
here it's like
when you're in a stagflation world like
we are which is simultaneous recession
and inflation that's not normal you
usually have one or the other and when
you have that kind of macroeconomic
condition
um Keynesian policy tools do not work
so if the FED tries to restain re
inflation by raising interest rates like
it's doing it's going to trigger a worse
recession if it relents like you're
saying down the road
by cutting rates or or stopping it's
going to exacerbate the inflation and so
the FED is a one-trick pony you can't
use expansionary contractionary fiscal
policy to control stagflation the answer
here and this will be for the campaign
in 2024 is the only solution is
structural structural changes in the
economy and right now what we need to do
in the very short run is for Kevin
McCarthy and the Republicans to hold the
line and get a deal where you cut back
some of those extravagant expenditures
by the Biden regime because part of the
inflation is what we call demand pull
inflation too much money chasing too too
many Goods that would be that would be a
a good step
um and the other kind of inflation you
have is costs push right it's the worst
kind of inflation and that's the food
and energy type inflation and that's
where you need the structural solution
so pre you watch president Trump he is
going to run on the restoration of
strategic full-structum energy dominance
so that we can go back to where we were
which was the incredible position of
being the number one petroleum producer
in the world and a net exporter
determining the price of oil in World
Markets rather than what we are now
where Biden has ceded that not just to
Saudi Arabia but the Russia wrote a
substance about this kind of stuff I do
it's like like right now Putin needs a
hundred dollars a barrel of oil to fund
his War Machine Saudis need 85 dollars a
barrel to fund their social welfare uh
bribery machine what they do the Saudi
deal is they pay off the people there
from throwing them out
um at knife Point by giving them a bunch
of government services right and so
we're gonna have oil which is going to
be 85 to 100 that's going to drive up
food prices uh for the next two years
um instead of the 60 Barrel oil we
averaged under Trump so that that'll
give you a flavor but
you know if if uh God forbid I were Fed
chair I'd be telling
the the White House and the Congress is
hey I can't solve this problem alone for
you you need to take the appropriate
steps you I'm raising race to control
inflation and Congress and Joe you're
you're passing massive spending to bills
which we don't need which you're pushing
inflation out of control yes sir I
happen to agree with you on one thing
there is American Energy
things so it's like
he's troll
energy energy Independence yeah um and
in this room yes all of us in this room
um are all about drill baby drill yes
and because what you can do in Anwar
what you can do in Permian Basin and we
all know you were speaking about the uh
economic viability cost per barrel yeah
we all know what happens at sixty
dollars a barrel below sixty dollars a
barrel we can't do anything in North
Dakota with the Shale because we have
like a we have like a 55 extraction cost
although we're getting better that's
right it's moving targets it's come down
but but yeah I tell you your point by
the way Us in Canada with the Alberta
Sands yeah that's why the um Saudis six
years ago artificially created it down
to 45. and they wanted to keep it below
the extraction capability of the Alberta
shell and the uh and Trump got all over
them for that correct so number one
energy Independence you're correct so in
other words for people who are paying
attention here Drilling is good sensible
drilling is good sensible drilling makes
you independent of other people because
you can take the oil that we have here
first and second of all over stimulus
when you're talking about demand pull
that's what people seem to understand
when you give 1.6 trillion dollars to
the American people they don't put it in
their bank account and and buy you know
regular consumer staples and get through
covid they go out and buy a ton of crap
yes and it creates its own inflation not
with not only with the demand pull but
also the value of the currency value
because you just what you did to M1 and
M2 because you throw all this money into
the into the barrel yes last question we
last uh conversation so you see yeah
we agree more than you think just so so
you know where I stand on the climate
change issue if you believe in climate
change there's only one way to solve
that problem that's carbon capture on
the supply side you can't have the
American people uh just unilaterally
disown arm on the oil drilling and
expect India and China and the rest of
the world not to stay on carbons but
anyway last time I do a 30 electric cars
in California
last thing here this just happened
yesterday okay new mortgage fees spark
controversy they were talking about this
as a possibility it's officially
effective mortgage fee at 740 credit
before
1750. now three thousand sixty two
dollars just because you have good
credit 250 bucks a month please you pay
lesser fee for having worse credit bad
credit yes and this is calculated at a
350 000 mortgage 20 down you're paying
thirteen hundred dollars more fee for
being responsible with your credit by
the way Finance of 350 mortgage it's
more like 600. I don't I don't normally
have high blood pressure just the
opposite but when I saw that cat this
woke these woke fools are just
destroying this country they're sharing
the economy the political system culture
the judicial system and that's why we
got to take back Trump's America that's
this 2024 election if we don't take back
the house and the Senate with Trump
Republicans and the White House this
beat will go on it's like uh they're it
just no no so can we play one game for
two minutes sell this to me be a devil's
advocate and sell it
now the common sense makes no sense but
actually
try to make an effort Tom to sell this
or Peter how do you sell this
okay
um
so I'll be I'll be Biden
um what was the question what are we
talking about
um
so it's the first thing is I'm gonna
help first-time homeowners who are from
lower income because mortgage insurance
and there's a part of this that adds to
your payment so I want to help them but
because it's coming from the federal
side you know we have to have an offset
and the offset is going to be other
people are going to pay more and folks
folks come on now a tax pays for
battleships and for social programs and
a lot of other things and the wealthier
people pay more tax than these people
think of it that way how would you sell
it how do you sell this I'm really
trying to figure out like I'm trying to
well I'm trying to sell it on the
inequitable tax base because that's how
it's been how do you sell this well you
can't sell it because it makes no sense
I mean the reason that I think I found
issue with this it's not exactly answer
your question but my issue is you know
I've made my name at least in the social
media World about being smart with your
money being prudent with your money you
know being having fiscal conservative
with your money and
paying off debt saving money investing
put it in index funds buying REITs just
driving up your credit score doing
everything you should be doing to have a
good framework for your finances and
then enter this where it's like yeah
turns out we don't need to do any of
that because uh we'll give you a better
loan and if your credit score sucks it's
all good so it it to me it's sort of
just the antithesis of what you're
willing to listen to where you sell
something how do you sell Obamacare okay
you can sell it how do you sell you know
how do you how do you sell this how do
you sell this hey because you are
responsible you got great credit 740
that means you're rich so you can afford
to pay 1300 more to the poor man who is
not responsible with his credit because
that's what we got to do which is a
noble thing to do just because you have
a good credit score doesn't mean you're
rich just means that you're not exactly
drowning in debt and you're paying your
bills on time you're doing what you
should be doing so you can hopefully
become rich I know a lot of broke people
with great credits yeah I know a lot of
great people you know poor people with
credit anyways Peter it's been great
having you on we're going to put the
link below to your sub stack Rob again
as well as the book folks if you haven't
ordered it yet go order the book as well
as subscribe to uh Dr Peter Navarro's
sub stack as well aside from that I
think today is what today's Thursday so
we've got no other podcast or we do have
podcasts on Saturday Saturday morning
yes Saturday morning temple temple will
be on the podcast
this afternoon I've been at Temple's
shop out and the Blue Ridge Mountains
there where it's like a little more
rustic okay they're a little more rustic
well he had animals chickens running
around in the yard a little dusting
that's cool well we got chickens here as
well but they're different kinds of them
she's slumming it down here in Palm
Beach right very cool well the P Dr
Peter Navarro again hey thank you for
coming on this was fantastic yeah
greatly enjoy this anytime take care
everybody bye bye-bye